alors bienvenue à la planète bienvenue
bonsoir bonjour bon matin et fait ou que
vous soyez on est là nous toujours à
montréal
ben oui bon alwyn en passant à oui parce
que là ça 7 heures sur deux jours
maintenant on expliquera sa plus tard à
l'émission pourquoi on à l'halloween en
deux journées
dépendamment de la ville où on habite au
québec en ce moment c'est une journée
venteuse si on veut parler des choses
importantes journée venteuse encore
c'est la pluie hier tout ça sans
l'automne sur montréal et bien sûr on a
des couleurs d'automne ici qui sont
atterrés un studio tales des feuilles
mortes
et ouais c'est daniel jobin bonjour
bonjour je ne suis pas mort tu incarnes
11 bien vivant mais jeudi mme aubry de
la section anglaise se joint à nous
bonjour mal qui ronge au projet encore
une fois vous n'avez aucune idée du
sujet de l'émission c'est la norme et
pour essayer de réparer la faire on va
vous présenter la vidéo 5 images et nos
internautes dans le monde entier peuvent
également regarder ces images et voir si
vous pouvez déterminer le sujet
démission aujourd'hui c'est très facile
je vous dis d' avance donc si vous
devenez pas c'est dommage
voici donc la vidéo numéro un à
l'émission aujourd'hui
première image je pense que tout le
monde la connaît selva attenberg ouais
bien lancé deux nuages vancouver non ça
c'était le gâteau qu'elle a utilisée
pour traverser très bien quand tu es
troisième image mais c'est chiant
ah ben oui les changements climatiques
peu importe je pense que vous pouvez
même et encore ah oui mais oui parce
qu'on se demandait comment elle allait
retourner chez eux
on va la laisser de côté un peu m'ont
pas parlé surtout de l'objet qui se
trouve à la droite
l'effet greta feinberg sur la honte de
prendre l'avion
ils appellent ça en suède d'où elle
vient le flic scam
c'est un mouvement qui a pris naissance
récemment à tel point que l'on regarde
les chiffres du côté de l'aviation
baisse je pense de 4 5%
ces dernières - derniers mois des gens
qui se trouve dans les avions en suède
et puis c'est le train qui a rattrapé la
sphère qui a été recherché ça s'est
passé dans un pays tout petit minuscule
comme la suède
mais au canada comment ça peut être
présente cette honte de prendre l'avion
nous prendre le train c'est pas évident
faire boire l'eau du canada mais
justement parce qu'il ya beaucoup
d'autres pays dans le monde qui ont le
train à haute vitesse
tandis qu'ici au canada avec les grandes
distances que nous avons entre villes on
n'a toujours pas vraiment train à haute
vitesse
oui on n'a pas de concentration de
population comme c'est le cas en europe
traverser les prairies canadiennes quand
vous passez par le manitoba la
saskatchewan il ya beaucoup moins
d'habitants que dans des endroits comme
en europe donc faire un train se serait
très cher et pas nécessairement
économiquement tête mais vous le savez
le changement climatique c'est un défi
planétaire donc même le même si les
canadiens disent c'est pas facile chez
nous c'est pas possible il ya sûrement
des affaires qu'on peut entreprendre
pour essayer de diminuer à tout le moins
la pollution créée par les avions est
notre transport grâce à ces avions c'est
ce dont on va discuter aujourd'hui où
aller de l'option total boycott à
l'option pas de problème on continue
comme ça
d'accord c'est l'émission aujourd'hui on
a deux éviter qu'ils se connaissent en
ce domaine est d'abord voici le jeu de
la grosse boule il y en a trois par
émission le premier jeu vous perdez
seulement 20 brûle il ya cent bus la
perte par émission en général et au
moins un d'entre eux qui restaient
debout à la fin de ce jeu de quilles
on a besoin d'une action par ici vous
l'achète déboule aujourd'hui ben ali
si on y va il ya deux boutons il ya deux
boutons à la grosse boule ce qu'il faut
faire les deux en même temps ça j'étais
bien manier la faire c'est tout faux car
le sens voilà vous n'êtes pas habitués
dans disco des années sportives
alors voici la première question alors
on arrête de danse et on écoute voici la
question numéro 1 compléter la phrase
suivante 1 km en avion pollue plus qu'un
kilomètre en auto deux fois plus ça
c'est la réponse à cinq fois plus qu en
auto ou
dix fois plus quand on voyage en avion
là ça pollue combien de fois plus du
kilomètre quand nos taux un décollage
cette fois dix fois plus la haute
altitude
moi je voudrais quand des colas et 1000
milliards à l'infini de plus parce
qu'une tour des cancres armes mais
effectivement ça décolle quand ils
arrêtent et d'écoles dans le sens de
partie aussi alors je marque valais avec
bessat bourg est plutôt bon
on présume qu'on parle quand l'avion et
dans les airs hautains attitude voit le
oui le bain du point a au point b au
total c'est quoi moi j'ai la vexer c'est
dix fois plus et b 5 fois plus ça y est
surpris vous avez tous perdu des boules
à voici la barre et trans deux fois plus
la main ouais deux fois plus mais ça moi
aussi ça m'a étonné je me suis dit quand
même c'est rien ça mais c'est quand même
beaucoup face à lyon à pistons en avions
jets à bon voila l avions jets deux
moteurs 47 et une chose si vous n'êtes
pas responsable des enquêtes vous alors
il ya quelque chose d'intéressant
normalement lorsqu'on prend l'avion on
fait de plus longues distances
donc en fait on pollue beaucoup plus que
si on prend la voiture pour aller faire
des courses ou cour décide la même
journée aux enfers tout les mêmes
courses dans un endroit circonscrit pour
moi de parler de ça c'est un boxeur ce
que vous gérez vous passez à la distance
brieuc où j'ai vraiment ma vie où ma vue
alors écoutez je voulais car un dire que
si on devait mettre les choses en
perspective cet important sinon son
super c'est que on peut faire dire
n'importe quoi aux chiffres mais si par
exemple le transport aérien était un
pays il ferait partie des dix pays les
plus pollueurs au monde
ça vous donne une idée de la
contribution de l'aviation à la
pollution internationale on va se
tourner vers notre première éviter
aujourd'hui pour discuter de cette
affaire des moyens pour essayer de
resserrer ce problème là lé d'équiterre
c'est une organisation québécois je
précise pour nos acheteurs et quand j'ai
vu les québécois s'étaient vus d'or il
on sait ce que c'est mais pour le reste
de la planète on s'est peut-être pas
c'est une entreprise à but non lucratif
qui a pour mission de contribuer à bâtir
un avenir plus propre et pour la santé
tout ça pour tout le monde et propose
souvent des stratégies d'intervention et
pour nous en parler aujourd'hui de ce
problème de la pollution aérienne on à
caroline ne brouille est experte un
changement climatique maintenant
brouillette bonjour bonjour en partant
des non-partants lavaud bureaux sont
plus propres que les nôtres j'imagine
c'est parce que vous voyez pas mon
bureau le tout les choses sont rangés
derrière moi mais moi c'est autre chose
d'accord écoutez il ya des gens qui
laissent flotter l'idée de boycotter
carrément l'aviation civile où se situe
équiterre dans ce dossier dans cette
affaire mais nous d'abord c'est
important de l'année dans une crise dont
on ressent déjà on est en europe des
canes qui dans le contexte cet appel au
boycott lancé un appel à l'imagination
de réfléchir au monde de demain qui sera
très différente du monde d'aujourd'hui
c'est une question qui est sensible
quand on parle du voyage en avion pour
plusieurs personnes
c'est de dans les repas et 2 des voix on
a des souvenirs on vit des émotions
fortes
mais c'est quand même un appel comme je
dis rien au fond pas et a comme quand on
fait un jet à couper dans ce qui est
super pu finalement alors est-ce que
vous avez des propositions nation vous
du transport aérien pas souvent été la
cible des accords internationaux au
niveau des changements climatiques
si vous aviez quelque proposer quelque
chose à mettre quelque chose sur la
table à une prochaine réunion
internationale ce serait quoi
spécifiquement d'abord vous l'avez dit
le secteur de l'aviation internationale
l'accord de paris parce qu'on sait pas
où comptabiliser les émissions dans les
pays où l'avion décolle donc payer
arrive cela étant dit il ya un orc
anisation civile internationale de
l'aviation civile internationale pardon
qui régule le secteur des voyages
internationaux qui nous on est
définitivement des propositions
politiques publiques qui vont viser
d'abord et avant tout les gens qui
voyagent le plus souvent et avec
l'impact climatique le plus grand donc
vous pensez à part ouvrons les voyages
d'affaires
il ya plusieurs compagnies d adopter des
pratiques de deux téléconférences doté
des technologies de téléconférences
d'affaires la superstar dont ensuite les
aides privées les viets privée parfois
facile km pour lui de faire 50 % plus la
proportion des jets privés dans l'apport
des du co2 ou de la pollution par
rapport à l'aviation commerciale
en fait on le poste et des données qui
étaient mes voyages et les les copier
table de recul et non pas commenter la
raison pourquoi on occulte
c'est une personne qui m'a plus grands
l'impact 5.5 fois de plus durant
laquelle quelqu'un qui voyage en classe
économie c'est parce que la question
climatique c'est un enjeu de justice et
d'égalité les effets des changements
climatiques affectent en premier lieu
les personnes qui s'en sont le moins
sept fontaines
par exemple au canada sa créance est
malvenue dans les taxis par exemple les
personnes qui voyagent dans le nord du
pays les communautés autochtones on en
lit donc y'a vraiment 71 sociale
ascendante et nous donc on freine avant
ce voyage qui sont super si délicat les
communautés marginales vite son enfance
ce sont les plus affectés par les
changements climatiques soient taxés
puis je sais donner une étude récente de
l'université d'oxford qui dit que
jusqu'à 50 % des voyageurs dont qui
voyagent en 1 min 50 % de leur voyage
il n'attend que c'est une bonne place
ou comment les voyages en avion
je sais une question ou sommes-nous dans
le développement du carburant
renouvelable ou biologiques pour les
avions est question que le secteur de
l'aviation regarde de manière également
au québec un groupe de travail il
exprime t il faut pas lui mais en
parallèle donc ce qu'on peut faire pour
l'état mais lorsqu on n'aurait pas le
même problème qu'avec internet on sait
où on taxe au point de départ ou au
point d'arrivée parce qu'on a les mêmes
problèmes avec gaffe à l'heure on peut
pas les taxis c'est très difficile et
pour l'aviation civile
j'imagine qu'on pourrait faire face au
même problème est factuellement faux
problème est complexe le plus complexe
faut toujours comparer les coûts d'agir
avec élevé ça demande un leadership
politique sa demande la coordination
internationale
mais on peut et on voit là avant le
passage de greta qui a porté à notre
attention le fait qu'on peut voyager
d'un continent à l'autre et même à
l'intérieur d'un continent sans utiliser
d'avion ou même de véhicules avec
qui fait du bruit il ya pas mal de gros
moteurs avance avant cette arrivée avec
cette conscientisation l'a inscrite
équiterre s'était assise avec d'autres
organismes au québec ou au niveau d'une
coordination d'une conciliation je ne
sais pas il ya est ce que c'est vraiment
une priorité ou bon c'est quelque chose
d'aussi de plus cela qu'il va falloir
essayer de l'examiner nous on compte un
groupe de l'aviation civile demande aux
catégories de vol dont je parlais en
europe qui s'appelle merci beaucoup
caroline de nous avons rapporté ces
informations du front parce que c'est on
est en guerre contre quand la pollution
c'est clair et net
enfin pas toujours clair et net même
mois on y travaille merci beaucoup et
puis bon succès dans vos projets mais
alors c'était caroline brouillette
experte en changement climatique à
ictère ici même à montréal c'est leur
siège social qui s'y trouvent pour
l'ensemble du québec
ils ont reçu un bureau à québec pour
ceux qui s'y intéressent écouter avant
d'aller d'un autre expert qui a
certainement son cloche très différents
nous proposer nous avons la grosse boule
qui va tourner pour un deuxième fois
cette émission combien de boue la paire
maryse je pense que c'est 30
à la deuxième question et vous avez
perdu combien de boulot premier jeu de
tous les deux que les deux va donc on
est à 80
il en compte combien oui c'est ça
j'avais globalement perdu déjà cale en
egypte un beau père dont n'ont pas de
gagner parce que dans le passé ont gagné
des règlements palmas et paloma qui est
venu ici à l'émission martinez qui est
venu ici en disant je trouve ça trop
simple votre formule si on perdait
plutôt des points ça serait plus drôle
je jouais infections de police quand il
internet contre les infractions des
pointes de mérite alors 2e tour napt
grosse boule voit si on affiche cette
question pour tout le monde pour le
plaisir de tous
combien de temps elle va m'en fous je
vous prépare de ça il ya eu une
compagnie aérienne australienne qantas
oui elles en valent c'était il ya
quelques jours le 20 octobre dernier
ils sont partis coins de new york ils
sont partis de temps déboires de new
york qui sont allés jusqu'à signer plus
long vol dans l'histoire magnifique
mémoire 19h16 et 16 minutes en troll est
passée juste du rangement sap a pas de
bus courses à faire là et c'était dans
un de ses 787 en vain de calyon qui
empruntent et consomment moins de
carburant
voici la question combien de tonnes de
kérosène navettes ont chargé à bord de
ce vol le plus long au monde et s à
quarante et une tonne b soixante et une
tonne ou c'est sans une tonne et je vous
ai dit si ou dennis nona disent combien
pèses l'avion 2 133 tonnes mais de
l'avion l'avion chargé chargé moi je
n'ai jamais poussé sa une tonne de
carburant
moi c'est beaucoup mais comme ça pour
moi je vais aller complètement l'opposé
cher 41 48 ans parce que c'est un avion
très performant a commencé je ne sais
pas la mouche
je me dis qu'elle est là moi si du point
de menacer des passagers on épluche la
bonne réponse pour le plaisir de tous et
chacun
ouais c'est pas mal de carburant
autrement dit on brûle du carburant pour
transporter du carburant pour
transporter les gens c'est comme d'aller
sur la lune ses principes
si jamais vous avez voir servir des vous
allez chercher à la cense
pas ceux d'essence et où chaque point ni
le bidon doit être remplie de liquide
c'est lourd et dense et ça c'est
seulement ce vin libre les bidons de 20
litres comme plutôt standard et c'est
lourd donc moi c'est pour ça que j'ai
opté pour 120 kg donc je suis à 50 et
monsieur étape est toujours à 90
toujours les deux prochains jeux se fier
à 50 boules à enjeu devant ce qui va se
passer on va aller dans notre prochain
éviter il s'agit de monsieur meyrannes
ebrahimi directeur de l'observatoire
l'aéronautique et de l'aviation civile à
l'université du québec à montréal
alors on va aller lui parler d'un onu on
est sur le point d'établir la
communication et 8 d'abord c'était
facetime pour la première fois cette
émission ah oui et puis maintenant c'est
skype et nous voici maintenant notre
invité bonjour aux professeurs oui
bonjour alors merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté notre invitation vous êtes
invité ici parce que vous êtes un
scientifique que vous êtes quelqu'un qui
vous intéressait beaucoup question de
calcul d'argent de technologie également
mettre les deux ensemble vous pourriez
président d'une compagnie d'aviation en
clair et net je vous savez comment c'est
vrai ça fait rêver un mois j'étais en
afrique je regardais les avions décoller
à atterrir mais je peux parler d'un jeu
devait atteindre tout le monde
l'arrivée des vacances pour retourner au
canada
écoutez vous avez écrit là sur ce sujet
de l'aviation et vous êtes je pense
complètement con tu lisais de boycottage
et ou de honte par rapport à la diète
l'utilisation de l'avion vous pensez
qu'il ya des pistes de solutions qui
sont devant nous clairement le problème
c'est que on doit pas tomber dans une
position dichotomique par rapport à ça
c'est pour ça j'ai toujours critiquer la
pollution de greta autour de la question
de l'aviation son mouvement et mark bray
côté l'avion ça n'a pas de sens par
contre ça ne veut pas dire que le sait
pas parce qu'on soutient l'aviation
qu'on n'a pas ddd générer des
préoccupations environnementales
écologiques
le charnier dans mon quotidien je n'ai
jeune je pratique ce que je dis c'est
que il faut être pragmatique si
aujourd'hui vous voulez partir de
montréal à partir s'ils voudraient de
paris à sydney l'avion il se trouve que
c'est la façon la plus rapide
toutefois aujourd'hui on est arrivé à
une utilisation une consommation géant
venir de la nation qui n'est pas
raisonnable par exemple si on fait un
trajet de 300 kilomètres jusqu'à 4 500
km prendre l'avion ça n'a pas de sens à
ce moment là on peut avoir le transport
connectez-vous peut avoir le train qui
est beaucoup plus sains plus
intéressante vous écologie alors donc il
faut il faut essayer de faire la part
des choses saluer les efforts qu'on fait
dans la console dallas jeudi les dates
dans les technologies pour essayer de
réduire l'empreinte carbone des avions
mais on n'est pas associé ça a dégénéré
une autre façon de faire par exemple
j'ai dit au québec on veut enlever par
exemple donné de beaucoup de souvent sur
250 mille dollars par an et un million $
pour que mel une compagnie s'installe à
sherbrooke
ça n'a pas de sens vous venez faire une
distance de 150 km en avion pour venir à
montréal alors qu'elle craint alors
qu'un autobus et de l'argent que nous
écologie parcours paris montréal dans
notre bus ou en train cette idée de
soyons responsables pragmatique essayons
de voir comment on peut devrait combiner
le meilleur des moments
est ce qu'il ya des gouvernements d
administration de villes qui font des
bons choix plus écologique avec
l'aviation ou dans ce domaine
tout à fait alors eh bien à voir qu'il
faut souligner c'est que dans les
compagnies aériennes le fait est
écologique c'est-à-dire réduire
l'empreinte carbone c'est à dire réduire
la consommation de kérosène
ce n'est pas par altruisme ou un désir
de
de générer de propager les idées
écologistes de savoie qui sont
économiques comme le prix de pétrole
rondes ainsi par exemple les compagnies
comme air canada c'est 4 à 5 millions de
dollars dont plus de coûts d'opération
alors donc vous comprenez que si à
chaque fois on aimerait aller chercher
les avions donc plus écologique certes
perd toute sorte par exemple de ces
dernières années on a fait beaucoup
d'efforts au niveau de la manière de
décoller et atterrir les avions est ce
qu'on appelle les approches comment on
fait par exemple les avions qui roule
sur la cuisse pour rouler avec un seul
moteur
côté moteur tout ça pour réduire la
consommation de
pour revenir à votre question oui il y
en a plusieurs par exemple prenons le
cas de klm
aujourd'hui si vous voulez partir
d'amsterdam à bruxelles l'union
européenne et que vous avez un billet de
cas réels en fait vous n'allez pas voler
en avion vous allez voyager par train
parce qu'on estime que le tram et plus
écologiste et plus économe et que tout
le monde est d'accord pour dire avec les
trains les tgv les trains à grande
vitesse canada donc c'est plus
écologique de faire ça d'autres il ya
des efforts qu'on entre en faire
certains pays ont commencé d'ailleurs
c'est l'objet de discussions de ronnie
wood au niveau européen pour voir est-ce
qu'on peut par exemple taxer les courtes
distances en avion taxi pour pas qu'une
prix soit attrayant si vous avez pas
avoir un peu un trajet de bari bordeaux
302 par ordre 500 km est ce que le tgb
prend à peu près le même temps une
partie du centre-ville
r centre-ville le temps était
approximativement la même chose avec
l'intégré est-ce que c'est préférable
prend l'avion donc on va prendre ce
genre de mesures mais il ya une
sensibilité par rapport à ça est en
train de se développer alors comme
toujours si généralement sa part depuis
mardi
et puis et puis mon bas une fois que le
mouvement est très dépendant du bac on
commence à en parler en année il ya un
problème d'infrastructures clairement au
canada comparé à la vente parce que
j'avais d'abord le concept des gares
intermodales où le train arrive c'est
pas loin de l'aéroport on peut la coque
connectée elle même un autobus tout est
connecté ici à mon rien au centre-ville
c'est l'autobus ensuite il faut aller 30
km plus loin pour l'aéroport et le train
c'est encore un autre 5 km à travers la
ville de montréal vient c'est un peu fou
hein quand même comme concept
d'organisation de de weeds
tout à fait et vous avez tout à fait
raison c'est à dire qu' on essaie de
penser le monde de l'aviation mais tout
simplement le monde du transport façon
générale l'avenir en fonction des
infrastructures du passé qui datent
d'une autre époque alors ça ça ne marche
pas dans l'esprit des gens ça ne marche
pas regarder sa clé ça fait certaine je
sais pas moi 30 ans 20 ans qu'on discute
d'un tgv dans le corridor québec windsor
on sait toutes les études montrent clc
rentrent à toutes les études montrent
écologique toutes les études mais c'est
largement mieux que les avions mais
alors comment ça se fait comme on n'a
jamais de l'avant avec l'idée paraît
aujourd'hui on a des technologies il ya
trente ans vous aimons mal écrit mal ne
le permet pas comment dans un climat
rôle semblable comme à l'infrastructure
de trappes est très très intéressant
donc on reste sur une espèce de vienne
suisses de degré d'immobilisme autour de
ça est ce que c'est la force de l'onu
dans certaines compagnies est ce que c
est ce que c'est une espèce plus
immobilisme politique et parce que c'est
la suprématie l'hégémonie de la pan
cette voiture tout ça fera en sorte que
même si on est conscient de nos à des
solutions techniques puisque visiblement
l'être humain n'a pas de solution lui
mais sa part sa part où je disais
quelque part que la pollution des avions
a été réduite de 75%
je sais pas depuis combien d'années mais
j'ai trouvé cette statistique un peu
ahuri 5 quand même est ce que c'est vrai
oui tout à fait je vous le confirme
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui par passager
par 100 kilomètres par rapport aux
années 70 on a réduit la consommation de
kérosène à peu près de 75% sur les
avions de nouvelle génération si vous
avez un avion des années 80 qui va là
encore c'est pas mal
mais dans les avions de nouvelle
génération on a réduit de 75%
donc la consommation kérosène par
justement là larchitecture d'un avion
par les approches de pilotage différent
par le fait de remotorisation par toutes
ces choses là aujourd'hui mais ça c'est
je vous le confirme c'est vrai mais je
vais vous poser les mêmes questions que
j'ai posées à notre autre invité on est
rendus ou dans le développement de
carburants biologiques ou renouvelables
alors ya deux écoles de pensée sur cette
question là on a là aussi l'idée c'est
de la nature ans à un système si vous
touchez un élément c'est rare que ça
reste là alors quand on parle de des
biocarburants il faut réaliser que par
exemple le brésil qui veut devenir le
champion mondial de biocarburant là on
s'est rendu compte que les pour la
production de méthane donc les
brésiliens ont commencé à prendre
quantités phénoménales était l'un des
terres agricoles type qui servait de
produire de la nourriture
donc pour les brésiliens on les a
transformés en terrain pour cultiver
donc finalement quelque chose qui va va
devenir biocarburants si on va vers les
biocarburants dans cet esprit là on fait
fausse route
autrement dit on règle un petit problème
dont on en crée un autre plus grand
parce qu'il faut pas oublier aujourd'hui
on pointe l'aviation mais il faut pas
oublier qu'aujourd'hui ce qui produit la
maxime le plus grand parti de la de la
pollution travers le monde le sait les
grands éléments terre eau tout ce qu'il
à l'aviculture
alors s'il faut mobiliser les
pourcentages très élevé de notre
production de gaz à effet de serre
produit un plan qui va servir de mieux
carburant pour les avions bien sûr qu'on
n'a pas réglé le problème il ya des airs
de me faire ce qu'ils sont en train de
faire pour essayer de voir comment on
peut développer des biocarburants plus
responsable mais on est encore loin
aujourd'hui de penser qu'un avion par
exemple peut partir de montréal à paris
un sens vous ressemblent carburant je
dirais responsable est propre
oui mais si un avion consomme moins il
ya plus d'avions dans les airs donc on
revient finalement peut-être à polluer
autant qu'à l'époque des années 70 et 80
il ya beaucoup plus de gens qui prennent
l'avion il y a plus d'avion dans l'isère
donc même si on a réduit la consommation
par avion on n'a pas réduit la
consommation totale
vous avez raison c'est pour ça que l'
approche système est qu'il approche
globale important c'est à dire il va
falloir réduire par le monde de
technologies de toutes sortes
la consommation des avions mais ça ne
doit pas nous donner bonne conscience
pour augmenter le nombre de vols ou des
lions c'est mon sang gisait par exemple
aujourd'hui une partie importante des
avions qui volent sont des monocouloirs
qui font des distances de 400 500
kilomètres que vous partez de montréal à
toronto en fait ça mais ça n'est pas un
trajet pour un avion ça n'est pas ce
n'est pas logique
aujourd'hui ça des fois je suis ch'ti
fiable de venir écouter on va vous
avions plus propre faisons la promotion
pour le trajet montréal n'auront pas
plus en avion c'est un logique là qu'il
va falloir qu'on vit dans sans bruit des
technologies propres permettant de
l'utiliser l'avion là où l'avion est
plus utile c'est-à-dire par des grandes
distances professeur ibrahim c'est
toujours un plaisir pour moi de vous
entendre même si vous n'êtes pas mon
émission je vous entends j'écoute avec
plaisir ce que vous avez à dire souvent
merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation aujourd'hui c'est toujours un
plaisir partagé
merci beaucoup alors c'était ibrahimi
directeur l'observatoire l'aéronautique
et de l'aviation civile à l'unité du
québec à montréal
bon j'ai pris ma décision c'est officiel
j'ai une résolution même si le nouvel an
est pas encore arrivé j'avais cessé de
prendre pour vous rendre au travail
chaque matin un hélicoptère
oui oui oui parce qu'une voiture
électrique thouet je conduis à
l'électricité mois et puis j'ai mes
propres panneaux solaires pour alimenter
mon auto électrique il faut nommer et
soulève un point est à la cense
avec l'idée de carburant renouvelable
par des plantes c'est vrai parce que ça
c'est la même situation qui est arrivé
aux etats-unis avec la production
d'éthanol pour les voitures ils ont
converti deschamps pour produire du maïs
pour des voitures et sa cause toutes
sortes d'autres problèmes
exactement comme il est dit je vous dois
apprécier vos questions aussi maryse de
conduisant un contexte vous connaissez
ça le monde navigation vous êtes vous
avez perdu votre permis là mais on garde
le cap parce que moi je pilote et des
petits avions ou des planeurs ça mais le
hall les engins qui volent cessna les
coureurs non mais les planeurs aller
plus loin oui les planeurs qui ont pas
de moteur diesel et au monde selon les
courants standard et lorsqu'on dessin
ben c'est un atterrissage d'urgence aux
praticiens genevois seul voyage dans le
futur pour les gens qui veulent la des
pays chauds qui viennent ce cadre on
sait pas où on sera mais on en place ça
serait bien
ce soit spectaculaire au fond ne pas
savoir où on va atterrir
on est prêts pour le dernier jeu de la
grosse boule et mona 50 boules à perdre
je rappelle que il reste sénat robert
leclerc jusqu'à maintenant tourner à 80
moule et puis 50 boul
voilà ce qu'il y reste alors pour ce qui
est de cette dernière question c'est
très facile de les voir à 58 cents un
piège le paiement se méfier oui tout est
ok mais pourquoi pas alors voici un des
petits plaisirs du vendredi c'est moi
d'accord oui faire moins bien paraître
c'est un mec de travail c'est à
l'altération puisque vous voici ce à sa
question intéressant sur le cas de ces
continents trafic aérien at il augmenté
le moins rapidement en 2016
est ce que ca l'amérique latine est ce
que c b l'amérique du nord est ce que
c'est c'est l'afrique où est-ce que
c'est dès le moyen-orient j'écoute les
statistiques pour vous c'est
depuis on a pris une photo en 2016 voici
l'état de la situation une augmentation
du trafic guéri en 2016
qu'est ce que ça donne là où ça -
l'augmenter le
rapidement sa a augmenté partout
rapidement mais le moins rapidement ou
en amérique latine en amérique du nord
afrique ou au moyen orient qui répond
quoi je dirais à aa a aucune peur je me
suis amusé alors j'ai continué mais qui
jetterait amérique du nord amérique du
nord parce que la croissance en afrique
d'après moi quand même assez importante
amérique latine je ne sais pas mais je
ne sais pas je vais essayer américaine à
prendre on va voir qui perd ses 50
boulevard d'alembert 50 boul on regarde
ça la réponse ça s'en vient vous en
faites pas comme oui bah oui j'ai même
les chefs pour vous notre vidéo numéro
38 28 cas 24 32
j'ajoute c'est aussi je suis flamand
ça vient ça remonte loin je pense qu on
appelle ça oui c'est numéro 5
on va regarder ça détend et je pense
c'est très intéressant vous allez voir
que ça c'est une question de croissance
de population aussi peut-être
puis je pense que maryse utiles sur la
bonne piste on allie shift est pas clair
nécessairement là parce que c'est quand
même petit mais 3 2 5% en amérique du
nord c'est la plus faible augmentation
en 2016 c'est suivi de l'afrique avec 5
28% suivie de l'amérique latine 5
ensuite il ya la zee suis un peu dans
another augmentation de population 1 8%
l'augmentation du trafic mais c'est un
c'est tellement rappelle pennac et
continent qui avaient une plus grande
augmentation nette et claire sur la
carte pour ceux qui n'ont vu ça ça passe
trouve rapidement ses bailleurs
mouvement alors là vous étiez à 70 vous
avez gagné madame j'ai gardé mes 50
vous bossez l'essentiel on peut je
laisserais patience interne on va rouler
vers le feu image la semaine je réponds
seulement par oui ou par non et vous
devez deviner quelle est l'image cette
semaine en guise
si oui avez des petits extraits une
petite musique danse et la musique
derrière mais pour quelle est sa serai
pas là lwin le ring et ça sonne un peu
comme des le sonar du sous-marin
mais alinghi et marisa la bonne réponse
halloween gates alors sur ces images de
notre dernière vidéo aujourd'hui vous
allez nous expliquer ce qui s'est passé
celle-là ces dernières sont real puis le
nord c'est tellement drôle
on ne remonte pas la vidéo on vous l'a
montré dans quelques instants banques et
au delà pour le moment les images qui
étaient dans les journaux pour dire aux
gens oublier la soirée de l'halloween de
tenir parce qu'il ya une petite ville à
l'extérieur de montréal sainte julie a
décidé que les prévisions météo étaient
trop affolantes et est parente qu'il a
levante et pleuvoir et qu'on ne pouvait
pas soumettre les enfants à ces
terribles conditions alors tout de suite
après celle qu'on voit à gauche
la mairesse de montréal a décidé
d'emboîter le pas ce qui fait que 58 un
taux qui m ont décidé de reporter
l'halloween au 1er novembre
sauf qu'elle veuille est aujourd'hui ils
n'ont pas hier donc on voit ce qui se
passe
autant en emporte le vent vous avez une
belle vidéo marc sujet là ça a été filmé
hier soir hier soir à mascouche qui est
un vil l'extérieur de montréal nord est
de montréal
et c'est vraiment l'imagination pour
combattre la pluie parce qu'ils avaient
des fortes lui là il faut quand même
sortir fait ce qu'ils ont fait la pluie
était intense mais ya les vents
n'étaient pas arrivées sont arrivés la
nuit dernière deux ou trois premiers
avec une tête tente on est passé à dix
et de tempo ici c'est un village tout
n'est pas la pluie mais si le vinci
était cet ami de la partie s'avère assez
sympathique mêmes félicitations maryse
avoir deviné là j'ai même pas eu le
temps de dire non mais là mais c'était
trop facile pour nous rappeler que faut
faire attention aux enfants peu importe
ce soir où la loi n'a lieu faut faire
très attention surtout quand les russes
ont sont brillantes de l'appui le reflet
des lumières pour les chaussures bateau
les conducteurs de retour
c'est difficile de devoir il savait que
ces réseaux sociaux et des jeux
seulement les bains la sinne f3 noël est
ce qu'on devrait changer mais la date de
ce n'est pas la fête de noël ou encore
le premier de l'an c'est sa douce
l'ancien maire de montréal une gravière
a aussi fait des tweets qui constituait
pas mal de maires actuels
valérie plantes justement avec cette
idée là ils ont qu un seul lit de noël
parce qu'il y avait une tempête de neige
je peux aussi ai-je aux passions pouvoir
lacunes mehrez cessé de changer
une fête comme sa chose spéciale non
c'est pour rire évidemment mais un
pouvoir extraordinaire que la même chose
qui est intéressant aussi c'est le
canada est grand n'est ce pas les des
conditions climatiques very énormément
et va coûter à l'autre donc partout au
pays
sicilia en tempête de neige qui est dans
le cas actuel dans l'ouest canadien
ils sortent s'il fait chaud ailleurs ils
sont mais vous savez qu'à laval qui est
la deuxième plus grande ville au québec
on a fait de loin quand même
ça s'est bien passé le match est
originaire de québec les gens aussi sont
sortis quand les deux jeunes auraient
veut faire l'halloween enseigner tout le
temps derrière on y canine en temps il
gens qui disent dans mon temps c'était
comme ça alors los angeles
ouais c'est tout bas je m'adresse pas
comment vous est aiguisée hier soir
voilà je sais que c'est trop personnel
bon écoute et utiliser tous les copains
travers la planète merci beaucoup
d'avoir été là avec nous aujourd'hui
marie jobin michael un triomphe en appui
à la semaine prochaine
barret
[Musique]